the council has discussed these two
files already over a year and I am happy
to say that we reached agreement both
with strong support from the Member
States
two years ago in Paris the EU promised
to cut emissions by at least 40 percent
by 2030 so we keep our promises the
lower CF regulation will make sure that
all emissions generated by use of soils
trees plants biomass and timber are
taken into account in the u.s. overall
target it will establish new accounting
rules and binding commitments for member
states to ensure that this sector will
always absorb at least as much co2 as it
emits the council also agreed on EU
priorities for the third United Nations
Environment Assembly meeting taking
place in December for sharing proposal
will reduce greenhouse gas emissions in
all sectors outside the repair Union
emissions training system such as
building transport waste and agriculture
up to 2030 through binding annual
targets for all member states the main
point of discussion has been the
presidency proposal for a safety reserve
allowing low-income member states some
more flexibility should they face
problems reaching their targets I remind
you that this is the first time in
European Union law that all member
states will have reduction targets with
the repeal Parliament having adopted
this negotiation position early this
year the adoption of the council
position is a major step forward to our
standing the proposals into clear
binding rules and preparations for trial
negotiations on both files can now begin